ladies and gentlemen here we go the
following is an exclusive presentation
Howard Stern channels for L Howard Stern
never stops
the Howard Stern channels present the
show that dares to enter the chaotic
brain of the mad genius known as sour
shoes this is embedded I'm embedded with
John Lieberman Michael delcampo has been
entertaining tens of millions of
listeners on the Howard Stern Show since
1999 you may be asking who the hell is
Michael delcampo in this series of
embedded we answer that question
uncovering the man or manchild behind
the myth nay the legend known to the
world as sour shoes Wow an ability to
spew out a seemingly unlimited amount of
type II a no cover versions of cheesy
pop songs is amazing in its own right
it's sours ability to perfectly
impersonate a number of high-profile
radio personalities that make him a
superstar his impression of stern show
executive producer Gary Dell'Abate is
indistinguishable from the real Baba
Booey it was okay okay so let me set the
stage was 30 years ago they were playing
at Shea Stadium and the number one song
in the land this week 30 years ago was
REO Speedwagon can't kick skip right
it's really his impression of former
Stern Show staffer and comedian Artie
Lange is hilarious and spot-on when she
made this bet she made alfredo
fettuccini alfredo sauce with the creamy
pasta and the list goes on and on Ronnie
the limo driver grips the road good it
handles okay why what do you go you got
a problem with that dude you got a
problem with that you're gonna come out
you're gonna go you want to drive with
my former Stern Show writer Jackie
Martling
hey how did the baseball teams go
without a single bad cross it all played
it was an all-girls team and then there
was Eva Miss Steve Langford prank calls
hello oh my god I can't so Green
definitely back in which sour called the
former Howard 100 News reporter over and
over life without a huge penis inside my
mouth solidifying sour shoes place in
the annals of show history hello save
life with my peers can you hear me hey
did you hear me listen I just want you
to know that I want you to go to jail
for this and I will be happy to work on
that it's the chaotic nature of sours
calls that has led many to view him as a
person completely unhinged from reality
but is he truly detached or simply a
misunderstood genius
oh I packed my bags and headed out 50
miles north of New York City to a sleepy
town called Mahopac they're near a
picturesque lake
I found the home where 41 year old sour
shoes resides but he doesn't live alone
the man lives with his parents we
arrived early one summer morning as
Sauer was frolicking around his backyard
pool his trusty piano and a phone he
didn't seem to mind getting wet already
dialed in to the stern show on the deck
beside him good morning sour hello
you're in the pool early there was a
turtle up here because of the
thunderstorm yesterday so I put him in
the water
Hey what what did the shy turtle say to
the hooker thanks for helping me come
out of my shell oh yeah wow you have the
keyboard set up right by the pool
as sour floated effortlessly on the
water I notice the toys strewn about the
backyard area you mentioned this idea
that you want time to slow down is that
why sometimes you do the baby voice is
that why I talked to me about that I
think that's what it is I think like I'm
not its I've had it so great since I was
a baby that I'm trying to hold on to all
those things maybe that's what it is
it turns out a lot of what makes sour
sour comes from a touching bond between
father and son
here's sours dad Mikey good morning what
the hell are you doing my good I hope
you have a great day at school
it is camp is it well that's what we do
and always tell me when I went out you
know different little things around the
house the exaggerated tease and Hess's
yeah
you know that was years ago that's what
slapstick was in a sense I laughed at
these days it was fun in the family even
from the very beginning sours Mother
Teresa saw something in her son
something extraordinary something
special when I gave birth to Michael
people friends of ours said to me so
what did you name the baby and I said
Michael Christopher and they said oh my
god don't you know about Michaels I said
what oh they're Devils I said well I
named my son after Michael the Archangel
Michael Dell Campos close bond with his
childhood also marked the beginning of
what would define him in the world of
the Stern Show I would always watch the
shows my older brothers and sisters were
watching like when I was really little
happy days was just finishing up John
Horner members I think the show jumped
the shark of 1981 when Fonzie I think
that was the 1981 it actually actually
had a nineteen share rating that's when
I was really must to catch on to that
sense as I used to I walked into the
Baker's when we got out of church and
they asked me for my name and I should
be on the phones but I was three years
old when I said like you started doing
voices at yeah Freight yeah hi I'm Henry
Winkler from from advanced mortgage
despite
being the perfect summer day for a swim
I left my swim trunks at home because I
was desperate to see inside sours
personal compound heading inside Casa de
sour we were led up a steep staircase
revealing an attic bedroom filled with
toys records and hundreds of old tapes
of the Howard Stern Show
some of them dating back to the 1980s
it's hot up here dude
yeah take me into your attic here um
these are my collectors trays I hope
you're spider-man that I got when I was
a little Jew
that's my tanks that I collected show me
how you play with these tanks oh not
Hydra German not riebeck we're in bed
sultry and then I act like this is
Indian point the American troops steady
as she goes steady as she goes I'm
backing up for a range view here's all
the vinyl yeah oh yeah you have a look
at all that vinyl yeah here's all the
vinyl here's some more the guitars uh
here's the tapes of the user types of
the show up in these baskets and in
those boxes and it's in those early days
that Sauer was first exposed to the one
thing every perfect childhood needs the
Howard Stern Show when I was really
little I remember being on my brothers
and sisters lap and we were picking my
brother up at school it probably was
last year at WNBC I was really small and
I remember it Howard's voice was a lot
higher than oh come on mommy come on
talk to me
come on Howard I'm not staying on the
end with you come on ma anyway Robert
Howard she doesn't want to talk today
coming up on the next episode of
headed inside the horrific accident
which may have changed Sowers life
forever
I'm John Lieberman this is embedded
listen this week for more sour shoes
embedded on Howard 100 and Howard 101 or
you can binge listen to all five
episodes with the new and improved
Sirius XM app learn more at Sirius XM
dot-com / app